[Music]
you're listening to
inside of you with michael rosenbaum
ryan good day sir
good day how are you doing uh rough man
it was rough i'm
doing okay i could power through it uh
as you guys know i can't thank you
enough for all the messages you uh you
left me
um about my dog irv had to put my dog
down
it was uh look at one thing i'll say i
strongly recommend
everybody if they're ever gonna put a
dog down their buddy
have someone come to the house and do it
instead of going to the vet or someplace
that the dog doesn't like
and he's uncomfortable it's a cold table
and it's leaving it
it was nice to have someone here it was
incredibly hard watching him go
um it was peaceful but it was just like
all of a sudden you got this pup that
you've been with forever and
and then his head's kind of limp and he
just lies there and he looks at you and
then they
inject the stuff and dude
tears just come out of you they just you
just you're flooded
but i will tell you that uh as much as
social media could be a pain in the ass
and annoying
uh the messages uh on twitter and
instagram and
the message board were just huge my
family my friends you guys stepped up
everybody stepped up and it just really
shows you how much love there is in the
world so that that helped me
substantially but uh you know i don't
want to talk every episode about the dog
but
irv is uh he's my best buddy and you
know
even like blanche my other dog she uh
the next morning i saw her laying on his
spot where he passed she never does that
and i and i heard him a few times during
the night i don't know if i was
hallucinating maybe it was the edibles i
don't i don't really know the answer to
that
but um anyway he has gone and he's with
me and
i love that dog and i got so many nice
you know celebrities also
you know henry winkler gave a shout out
and um
kevin conroy and my daddy johnny glover
from smallville and
love hewitt and trish helfer and just
just everybody just poured it on and it
was it was a beautiful thing to see how
many people cared and took the time to
message so i will say that
uh so thank you everybody out there for
doing that all my lovable patrons who
just
are endless they have endless love
they're a lionel richie song
right they're just endless love i want
to announce
stage it my band you can see the shirt
um we are playing another stage at april
24th it's a saturday
the end of the month uh this one's for
irv
is the show and uh it's a 2 p.m 6 p.m
pacific standard time show we're doing
two shows 2 p.m and 6 p.m
we're gonna play covers and originals
and all that stuff
you can go to stageit.com and type in
sun spin get yourself a ticket
also go to sunspin.com get yourself
shirts lunch boxes
hats coasters all that stuff and if you
want any inside of you merch
the inside of you store inside online
online inside of you online store
there's a lot of great stuff there
and uh smallville stuff and a bunch of
really cool things
well guys really quickly um these guys
aren't even a sponsor but i love them
so much my good buddy mike borga he's
introducing an 80 proof clear spirit
made coconut nectar to the u.s
it is amazing it's called lambonog like
a mashup of lamborghini and eggnog
they have been making this in the
philippines for 600 years but mike is
bringing it to the u.s
now it's distilled from the nectar of
the coconut flour
nothing else is added you get a clear
spirit and a bit of sweetness to smooth
out any day
with a sip of papa js you get the
brightness of intense sunshine
you get the earth and salt of coral and
volcanic soil
and you get that salty sugar of the
ocean from where it was made
papo jay's lambonag vodka
check it out man it's a little mon paw
company and i'd like to see him do well
he's a good dude and gives me some free
stuff and
um yeah also if you want to uh subscribe
to the podcast
or uh you know we can go to the handles
if you want to um
follow us on twitter and instagram on
instagram it's at insideyoupod.cast
at inciti podcast on instagram and
facebook and twitter is at inside of you
pod it's right here
so please follow us and if you want to
subscribe you go to apple
or you go to spa uh spotify or
uh please go to youtube as well and
subscribe to the show ryan inside of you
with michael rosenbaum on youtube
yeah please do that got a great show i
love having this guy on the podcast it's
the second time he's completely open
and fun and i miss him dearly he was my
father in smallville and i love him
because he's not a pain in the ass he
doesn't after the show he just goes okay
great was that okay
this guy just says whatever the [ __ ] he
wants and moves on
and i love those guests not that i don't
love the other guests too
not they're listening to this episode so
[ __ ] them
but uh yeah there's that so um without
further ado
let's get inside of the one and only
john
glover it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael
rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
look at your place it's it's so nice
have you never been here before well i
was at your one house when i had dinner
with you
it was me and alison and a couple of
people years ago
but i think he may have moved because
that looks way bigger yeah this is
uh this is big that's great
you had a nice pool and i got the heater
on
do you swim a lot do you skinny dip oh
god yes
well if there are no kids a lot of uh
a friend of mine um i was a friend with
janet margolin
are you aware of who janet margolin was
no um
she did cure delay that little move that
first movie that they did
together uh david and lisa and i did a
movie with her called last embrace
and she used to go out with woody allen
anyway she died
and she had she was a good friend we
made a movie together
and got to be good friends and she had a
little boy named julian
and uh um i guess he was like 12 or 13
when she died and he thought
he maybe had killed her or something it
was his fault that she died
and but but right last march
when i was here when all this was
starting to grow i was on the hike
and there was this sort of family of a
man and a woman and two little girls
and it was we cross it we all had our
masks on he said
are you john glover and i said yeah he
said
oh i'm janet markle and son he was all
grown up
what so so he started i mean we've
become good friends now
does he go skinny dipping with you no
because he's got two girls
well you know i'd skinny dip with you oh
no i know you would
i would buy him when he comes over he
loves to take off all his clothes and
jump wait wait who's this
byron byron burton byron i we know byron
by so you're assistant byron who's a
friend of ours he gets
he'll get naked oh god yeah he doesn't
use it
i think he's coming over this afternoon
because he's got um
some stuff for me to sign from the last
uh
virtual show we did right so you saw
batman and robin oh yeah when you were
on
a smallville that's how we all we we all
met you were
always so fit so ripped so
in just in tune in touch with your body
you're always just looking i'm amazed
myself
yeah you really didn't yeah i'm not that
way anymore
you don't work out you don't get ripped
up anymore or you don't care what
happens
well i care but i just am a bit lazy
about i'm you know my abs are kind of
gone i can you know i can suck it in
and stuff but there was a point where
where i started sitting in front of the
tv set when i wasn't working
eating whole packages of crackers i mean
there were some of the
comic-cons we did where my butt was so
big and i had a belly
i looked at the pictures i thought oh
john you're letting yourself go
stop stop eating at night i mean how
what age do you just stop
it's not like you stop caring but do you
have to be one of those guys who just
had you know he dies like in his 90s and
he's just all in great shape and he just
wondered he died on a run
or do you just kind of give up after a
while and say hey i'm in my 70s [ __ ] it
i'm going to enjoy life i'm not going to
worry about staying in shape i'm going
to grow my beard out and not give a [ __ ]
well i'm i miss being a um
it's harder to take my clothes off in
front of people now because i
i got some little uh you know love
handles some little they go away
but but but the hike around this
mountain
you know when last year was march 15th
when you saw it kind of had it was a
saturday
right because adam and i were both here
and i thought
okay at least two weeks we're going to
be quarantined
so it'll be hard for me in the you
thought after two weeks the bell was
going to ring and we could go back to
normal life right
so i know i was nine months alone in
this house
by myself and i i i started to talk to
myself
and now i talk to myself all the time
and i've become this old person who
talks to himself what would you say
anything i would just narrate what i was
doing and make jokes about it and laugh
like somebody else was there that i was
talking to tonight
telling my side of the story too did you
talk to your psychiatrist about it and
he said that was normal
i think it is normal because i've spoken
to a lot of other people
who were uh kind of all
on their own alone yeah in a home
i mean nine months i mean i i'm used to
adam being there all the time and
talking to him
but there was nobody there so i just
talked did he think he was losing
narrated my life to myself
did he was he worried about you never
too but i was at different accents and
everything i
i want to hear a conversation you might
have had i just said
well i'm walking to the front door i
mean i mean there's the stuff that that
my gran
was in my grandmother's house when i was
a little boy so i here i mean i could i
mean if we were up in the guest room i
would show you this little pied piper
and there's a picture somewhere of me
the same size as he is so
all these things are are in this house
that i bought
uh with adam uh not so lo uh
i don't even know how long ago it was
maybe 15 years or so i don't know
but i thought this would be a great
house to die in it's all on one level
it's spanning we put a pool in the back
and
there's a guest house and um and then
adam said no no
we got to sell the house so i'd walk
around the house
weeping because i thought i can't get
rid of this stuff
i mean it's stuff but it's stuff that's
been with me all my life that i know
so it's become this this sort of
museum of me i guess i don't know
there are all these things that i and
and then there's stacks of stuff
everywhere because we collect
so anyway i was here on my own so i
could make my piles and everything
well i talked to myself i think you
probably know that it doesn't shock you
yeah but i i yeah okay i will i'll
question myself more like
why are you doing this why are you
allowed yeah why are you doing this why
are you thinking like this
why are why these thoughts these are
these aren't real
well i don't know if i've done accents
but you know i i think when there's
people over the house or if i have like
a just someone around i feel more
compelled to
you know turn it on a bit oh you know oh
lovely look and i'll grab a little
trinket or a little a little
like a little doll or like oh looky look
and i'll just put on a show but that's
kind of me i'm
you know i need to always feel like i
have to put on the [ __ ] i do that
without an audience
well i think that's all right so then it
sort of turns crazy
and like an old guy who's 76 years old
but i let that this is a year now this
this stuff
wow because i stopped i stopped shaving
or cutting
anything on march 15th last year do you
think you'll ever shave it
yeah you do you think you'll go back to
clean john
you see i did this for that job that i
did walking dead fear the walking dead
fear the walking dead yeah and how many
episodes did you do
four i had a four episode arc my god my
god
i'm four into secrecy i can't talk about
it but i thought i mean i got the job
before all this happened
so so david letterman my agent called
and said
they're still probably going to do it
but we've got to find out
when it's going to be safe enough so
they started up again
in october uh so i was
from march 15th to october or something
around here
are you done filming yeah i finished uh
a couple of weeks ago how was it it was
fun they're very
oh they were very generous and so
welcoming and
really wonderful people they made me
feel
happy to be there i the problem i had
was when because the the walking dead
i'd never watched the show before
i mean had heard about it but it was the
violence because they'd have to to kill
him
forever they'd have to uh like
stick him in the head with a knife or
something right so
so one of the first things i had to do
was to poke a guy in the eye
and kill him forever
and it was this big stuntman that was
laying there on the floor and i
they gave me this sort of rubberish
knife and i
i mean they were very generous about
helping me and the cameraman said it's a
little awkward you
grabbing it maybe and he said well we
can get somebody just to hand it to you
so it'll be there
but it was the how you stick it in
right then they do the rest of it in
post but it was um
and you can't talk about this you're not
allowed to talk about it has an air jet
no no i'm sworn to secrets about who i
am and everything
but i just let everything grow and then
when it
happened i i sent him some pictures of
myself the way i looked and they went
yes like that they got very excited do
you make me feel good do you find it
more difficult the older you get maybe
this is a stupid question
to remember lines to uh just acting in
general
it's my fear the confidence i lose a
word
for something an important word i can't
i can't remember it or something will go
blank
i mean it just i mean i remember when i
was in my 20s or early 30s
learning a script over the weekend so i
could replace somebody
uh and i and i just went blind page by
page by page
put it in my head never had to go over
it again
i just knew it and and i
i have trouble uh keeping the lines in
my head now
yeah and and as soon as i start i think
okay you can do this you can do this but
there's
that thing of am i gonna humiliate
myself
because it is it's humiliating for me
because i used to be able to just
read it and know it like you do like you
used to i
like i used to it's harder now though
isn't it i'll be
i'll be 49 in july yeah it is hard it's
always been
for me i've had to go over it and over
and over and over and over just
so i have the confidence to because i
used to watch you on the airplane on the
way back on the weekends you know when
you went
we'd race for the see we've got the up
front seats
yeah yeah but i remember you'd start
learning them then
and i would i would kind of wait and
yeah i think my fear is that i don't
want to
i want to be so prepared that i just
want the lines to be second nature that
i feel like
that's how i tried to get them too but
it but but the first episode that i did
uh i thought i could do it better than i
thought so i i
i i the next script i had to spend much
more time and
start immediately as i got it just to
start sticking it in my head
because a a four-week rehearsal doing a
play
will get it there i found you know it's
it's harder i mean i used to be able
just to know it like
on day one or two or something but i
there were times when i don't even
remember having to sit down and learn
the lines
they just i did it enough that i just
knew it
do you still want to do plays do you
still want it yes oh my god
that's the easy part because you do have
that rehearsal
which which lets it get in there because
there's
there's something about starting with
with you think am i going to make
it through this big speech as soon as
that little
thing of am i it's like a flinch happens
and you think
and you tense up we had a great scoop
script supervisor marjorie
and i'd work and i'd work and i'd [ __ ]
it up and [ __ ] it up and come back
and then about the like the third or
fourth take it would just go
and she'd come over and i'd been through
such agony and she said or you can do it
like that every time if you want
[Laughter]
she had such a good humor about it
because i she understood i think
and that was on fear the walking dead
yeah yeah yeah
i mean it was i felt alive again because
i thought
god what's going to happen are we going
to ever work again
but but this the kind of weird part
about it was
that everybody's masked everybody that
makes me nervous actors are hearst
masked
and so you can't really you know see
what everybody's doing because you can't
see their
all you can see their eyes and not hear
them real well because they're a little
muffled
and i'm also getting i think a little it
may have got the wax
too much wax in my ears i don't know and
after lunch once i thought we were
moving on to another scene
and we redid the whole scene that we'd
done all morning
and i i just i i like went haywire
and thought i can't do it i know it's
already gone from my head
so i made it terrible so i i'm
learning through through each time but i
i it felt so good to be back at work
because i thought when is this going to
happen again and the theater stuff is
even
i mean that's going to be take longer
right oh and then they go
final touch-ups so all the actors
take their masks off and everybody else
is masked
and you're just feeling naked and like
okay if
i stand here got a half an hour maybe 15
minutes if somebody
but but we got tested four times a week
and before i would take the airplane to
get to austin
they would send somebody to my front
door to test me there
and then as soon as i get off in austin
the next day they sent me to do the you
know the deep
the deep nose test first right which i
learned how to take
the first guy that came to my house here
was
he had a name that sounded like i
conjured up
an older kind of jewish guy with
appearing
well like a six foot two latino man who
was just
like like david or something appeared at
my door
and he said i'm gonna go deep what i
want you to do
is to breathe very slowly through your
nose
so as he i mean it was almost like
it didn't hurt at all and he went deep
too and i'm sure you made a smart ass
i said that he wanted to go for a swim
in the pool that's right
i was waiting for it but he said
he said no i've got some other people to
test i said well i'll be here all
weekend if you're free
inside of you is brought to you by geico
uh everybody knows what geico is and if
you don't you should
uh they make your bundling policies
easier they make life
easier on you uh whether you rent or you
own a home mortgage rent it's always the
hardest thing to do but then you have to
send a payment here you have to send a
payment to your auto
you don't have to do that with geico
bundling policies with geico
geico makes it easy to bundle your
homeowners or your renter's insurance
along with your auto policy it's a good
thing because
we already have too much going on just
go to geico
it's so easy go to guidecode.com get a
quote
see how much you could save it's geico
easy folks visit geico.com today
that's geico.com
even a rosenbaum can do it
even a rosenbaum can do it inside of you
is brought to you by better help
better help online therapy uh one of my
favorites i love talking about this
sponsor because it's so easy for me to
talk about someone who gets therapy
someone goes to therapy somebody who
tells other people to go to therapy
because i see
how it works i see people improving i
see people who have
all these things bottled up in their
lives
and they just bottle them up bottle them
up and what happens it's called
explosion
and you don't want that explosion you
want uh you want to get these things out
healthy
ways natural ways and you know therapy
people ask me what therapy is and
therapy is anything you want therapy to
be
it's getting tools getting the tools to
help you with motivation depression
anxiety anger issues all these things
that come into play in life
in your lifetime relationships at work
it's time to stop being ashamed of
normal human struggles and start feeling
better because you deserve
to be happy better help is a customized
online therapy that offers video
phone even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to i
like to see my therapist i facetime
everybody but you don't have to if you
don't want to talk to them
you don't have to on facetime or
whatever and you know the great thing
about better help is
it's so much more affordable i've talked
about this ad nauseam but guys
you're not going to get a better deal
for therapy if you want to get yourself
into therapy this is the way to start it
um the therapists that i see are just
the prices are
exorbitant i just wanted to fit in that
word and by the way you'll have your
therapist in under 48 hours which is
fantastic so if you really are
ready for a therapist now's the time to
do it join the millions of people who
are seeing what therapy is really about
it may or may not be for you but it's
worth looking into because you
you are your greatest asset this podcast
is sponsored by better help and inside
of you listeners
you guys get 10 off your first month
at betterhelp.com inside
that's better h-e-l-p-com
slash inside get some therapy
you have such a body of work i mean you
won two tonys you've been nominated for
emmys you've
you know you're on small little together
you did gremlins you did scrooge you did
uh annie uh not at any hall you did any
annie hall right you were in annie hall
you did annie hall
julia i mean just tons of work what it
what
do you remember most fondly like what is
that piece
of work that you always say this was
whether it was big or small
this is what i want people to remember
me by or this is
i got a lot of them that i'm proud of
but one of the
most fun jobs i had was at one hiatus
from smallville um i had and i had to
fly to new york to audition for this
there's a show called the drowsy
chaperone a musical
yep and the guy that wrote it who was
playing the man in the chair
who had no songs except right at the end
there was a little thing he
did he's saying but it was a musical and
i've always wanted to be in a musical
but because i don't
sing on key they don't cast me in
musicals because i flinch and
and so miserable if i have to sing a
song but i was on stage through the
whole show
and sort of created it and i had the
best time because i was
on the musical stage and and
and the little song i had to sing i
would forever
start on the wrong key so you could hear
this piano down in the pit going going
don't here's your note but i usually
couldn't find
but it didn't matter i was having such a
good time you like to have fun when you
work
sure like what we did together i mean at
first i wanted to strangle you
i thought this guy is a pain in the butt
and then i realized that you were just
being lex
and so you were just well i think you
were doing this on purpose to sort of
get me pissed off
because the scene would work better what
i was now i started
remember uh there's a woman who's uh
who's a
um on the cnn now brooke baldwin i think
is her
yep her name who did who who i guess was
just starting out but
she was at one of those warner brothers
things
interviewing us all and she wanted to
she was work i think
yeah well anyway she's a cnn
girl now and she's really smart and
everything but her question was
who on the show do you really not get
along with
and i and i i said i
i finally walked away and said i don't
want to answer that question
but you came right to mind because you
kept you kept [ __ ] around all the
time
and then i started getting into it
because it was
it was a legs how early was this in the
show
well it went away pretty early but it
was just before i understood
well yeah because oh i was only in the
pilot
and then they just called me back for a
few times that first
that first time so i wasn't sure of
myself i mean i wasn't i didn't know who
lionel luther was yet i was you know
trying to figure that out
well i didn't think you liked me i told
you this many times i i remember in the
pilot
that was just like the first couple of
times i was
it took a minute but by the time we
started fencing by the time we started
there was there there was a time when we
then all of a sudden we realized we're
really good together
yeah you know when we realized people
are liking our what we're doing it's
working
there was a certain so as soon as you
showed me your balls that's when i knew
i could trust you what season did i show
you my balls
so many was it season two
[Laughter]
don't you you don't show on the first
time you're right but where it looks
like the girl's uh
we're in a trailer we're running lines
or something i'm probably in my
underwear and like jonathan
no you're hanging out of your trailer
sort of going like that and shaking them
well that's when you could do that i
don't know which is this
the witch is dead the witch is dead my
balls are here
oh but they're ground falls though great
balls of fire
thank you who is the who is the biggest
celebrity you've ever met that you got
uh star struck
uh i remember you telling me you met
barbra streisand and she wasn't very
nice
no i just didn't know what to say and i
knew she liked uh
uh aegon sheila that artist egon sheila
who who i patterned a whole character
looking after
um so she was at a party at the the
those songwriters that wrote a lot of
her songs the
marilyn and what whatever their names i
don't know they were there i was there
with michael feinstein
right and barbra streisand was there
with
the director who did what's up dog who
wrote the book
right used to be with civil shepherd
anyway so
i just sort of stood there uh listening
to her talk
she said she looked at michael feinstein
and she said are you the um
like that he said yeah yeah so but right
when it was sort of
time getting time to close i said
i i know that you have some egg on
sheila's where
do you keep them this is a really
strange
question and she got really defensive
and said why and and i said well i mean
why i said i said because he's a
favorite artist of mine and
when i heard that you you you had some i
wondered if
if like they were in a room or in a
hallway if
they were in a room where you could see
them a lot of the time or a hallway
where you just could pass bible
so that's and what'd she say i don't
remember
i haven't seen him she probably listened
but if at least i talked to her once
that's true uh i talked to her once too
i talked to him
but more importantly was the time that i
lit betty davis's cigarette
tell me about that well i was at rodney
mcdowell's and he had
i mean he would have these parties where
people were over i think this was i
don't know if this was a thanksgiving or
not but i remember
uh elizabeth taylor was there
um um um
um the guy who did the house of wax
vincent price vincent price was there
with his wife
uh betty davis elizabeth taylor because
i remember uh for desserts
there were different kind of cakes which
liz taylor was going crazy
and uh and betty davis sort of
hobbled into the room this was after the
dinner
and and and betty
this taylor said something like betty oh
come on look at all the cakes
and and somebody said something funny
that betty davis didn't like and she
hobbled away
and vincent price saw her and said oh
benny look at you you thought you were
so skinny but you got a little belly
and she really got angrier and walked
off
but it was it was quite a party that
you mingled with some of the greats yeah
yeah but jackie collins once uh called
me an [ __ ]
well was he right yeah i know i i was at
dinner at the bare walls and
roddy was there maybe um lee remy
i got to be really good friends with lee
raymond i love libra
from the oman we did this mini series
together and i
you know i'd done a movie i worked with
jane fonda and i've worked with ann
margaret and and there was always sort
of a wall up
but with uh lee she just was lee
she i remember i kind of got a lot of
this hair off and it was
like a crew cut and uh and she walked
into the i walked into the trailer where
she was getting
a makeup test or something and i said it
was real cheeklish and she
she came up to me she said tickle my
belly with that
and from then i just knew i was in i
mean i i we
we played these best friends i was like
this slob
and she was getting her son to murder
her father it's a great mini series
i love that you said on the last podcast
that you slept with freddie mercury
no i didn't say that did you not sleep
with freddie mercury somebody
i did a show with with a mark blum
god bless his soul he was one of the
first
people i knew to to die of the virus
um but he came in the first day of
rehearsal
and he said i heard you was slept with
the freddie mercury in the
hall of notes guy i said
where did you hear that he said i read
it on wikipedia
[Music]
for my podcast there's some they got it
from your podcast and somebody put it on
wikipedia well the little one from hall
notes we know that's true
uh john oates you had sex with but we
don't know about freddie so freddy
freddy krueger freddie mercury's not
freddie mercury you didn't sleep with
i think i did i mean
and i think that was him i mean was he
nice that mouth
when i saw that mouth on the thing i
said oh
i know that guy now did you do you
remember him being nice
what do you remember him being nice and
kind it was very nice
oh yeah you guys hook up you go your
separate ways nobody gives a [ __ ]
right and is that what happened you just
kind of had a fling
yeah look the club was letting out
it was like two or whatever in the
morning
i had been making a movie in munich and
i had some time off and i went to berlin
and i realized i couldn't understand
anybody still there so i
went to london where i knew some people
so so i i was and then i went back to
berlin
do you remember a conversation you had
with freddie that night maybe
anything bless you you just remember
having sex and you don't remember
talking like i'm writing this song
bohemian rhapsody nothing nothing comes
to mind
no no i don't think what we did
came up you know are
just two people who were attracted to
each other
and wanted to uh touch and that was it
and the next morning you left
he left that was it done i never saw him
again
i didn't get his number or anything well
did he just say well nice meeting you
you know it was a long long time ago i
don't remember
well what about uh john oates what about
him he's
very talented they had a lot of my
favorite songs on
i love the songs he didn't do any
singing though that time
what was what's your favorite whole note
song well they had so many good
big hits oh they had so many hits man
eater
adult education uh yeah they had a lot
of great songs
a man-eater man-eater yes
that well there you go so were you like
one of those guy i mean you were sought
after
especially back in the day like when you
went to a party people knew who you were
there oh that's john glover
did you feel that like people knew who
you were
no you didn't no i
don't know i sort of have to i felt that
they wouldn't remember who
that i met them or something i always
feel like that way too i think that's
some kind of insecurity we have
yeah well insecurity is useful you don't
want to get too cocky you know
yeah it's like it's like when what have
you been uh
incubated vaccinated not yet
okay well i i got it the place
downstairs
from us is is a place where they have uh
the shots
so um i can never remember the name of
it
in new york so i would go there every
morning because i was of age
i was 70 i was 76 so i could get it this
is when they were
had to be over 75 but i went in every
morning
and um and i was getting ready to fly
back to austin
and you know there was all the stuff
about the airplane so being on the
airplanes
and the airports and people so i give
her morning and the one guy
this beautiful black man named
justice who we've become friends but he
said why are you so angry
and i stopped for a minute and i said uh
no i don't mean to be angry if you
thought i was angry
i apologize but i'm frightened because
i'm gonna go on an airplane soon
and i'm the
the their variant changes now in these
so i i need a vaccination to feel safe
and one and finally one morning or one
afternoon around two o'clock the phone
rang
it was downstairs and they said can you
come now we've got a cancellation
i said give me five minutes i'll put my
pants on and be right there
so i went down and got my first and then
i went off to austin and i came back
and four weeks later because i hadn't
gone back yet
i got my booster and i didn't have i
didn't have trouble with my booster
but what i'm also saying is since i've
gotten my full vaccination
i've become even more careful with the
mask wearing
and the distancing i don't know why
but i just am that's that's weird that
you're vaccinated you
you feel like you're you know and you're
not just so i don't want to get cocky
about it well not only that because you
could get you could carry and give it to
somebody else yes exactly
so i'm urging everybody who's watching
this
to listen to to be helpful to your
fellow man
yes earplugs keep
i think i must have too much wax in my
ears don't stay in hey johnny what do
you
have left to do like look you're not old
you're 76 you're not old
but like you know do you want to keep
working to you
you die yeah yeah i want to go with my
boots on actually
i saw john glover die on stage but i
want to play prospero
um and then i there was this a reading
that they did
a year or so ago where they got
playwrights american playwrights to sort
of do
translations of shakespearean plays
there was some guy from oregon who had a
lot of money
and he loved to go to the theater but he
couldn't understand the shakespeare
language
so he paid a lot of money to get these
playwrights and i did a lear one
a friend of mine who i knew from when he
was in college when i used to go back
and
and help them out and tell them what
it's really like to be in the theater
i said john do the lear for us
so i thought leah i could never do
leader but i worked on it
i mean it wasn't shakespeare's language
but i worked on it and felt
i i think i understand enough that i
could
attack that but the but i want to do the
tempest i want to play prospero before i
go you want to die on stage you really
think that would be cool
well it would be easier for me because
there would be time to rehearse it
i mean she'll put the words
in my head and i'm
frightened of of the lying things now
it's
and they even offered me in um in
austin they said you know you if you you
we can do big poster boards so you could
read it
or we could put a a wig as they call it
a wig
a wig yeah a wick a wick or whatever
yeah
and you sort of talk and i and that
makes me frightened because it's gonna i
was it was de niro and um
uh marlon brando and uh brando wore one
and they all were doing it with the with
being fed the lines
but they all got mixed up because they
couldn't they were sending the wrong
lines to the wrong
person and everything it said it was a
mess but
but i know that richard easton who was a
wonderful actor who had a
kind of a stroke and and couldn't learn
lines
and jack o'brien was a good good friend
of his
who who taught him how to to use it so
he could
so he could do this play this is all i
know how to do is act
i mean that's that's what i do
i never had the weight table i never
i've been so lucky about
getting uh jobs
yeah you've always worked and you've
always gotten the lines out remember
when you're doing
a film or a tv show they could
you could take as many takes as you want
they cut around it we've had guest stars
who can't get one line and they look
better than us
after they edit it it's my pride i have
to get over the pride thing and think
okay
am i worth it and i'm going to take a
little longer than
than i used to to yeah to you know to
get a take that
i i was thinking of that some actors i
remember i was doing
one of those um um um
lawyer shows and there was this one
young actor who had a big long speech
and he i mean he'd go up and then he'd
start again and just
he'd know that they were going to be
able to cut it together
by him doing it but i always because i
guess i grew up on the stage
if i you know if i go up in the middle
of a line
it's like oh my god i have to start over
again
i know what is that about us i mean some
actors i've seen them miss
mess up over and over and they're fine
with it and then where i mess up one
line and i'm all of a sudden i'm getting
nervous and i'm getting upset and i'm
like
i just want to be perfect it's i think
it's we're striving for perfection
and it would be so nice to just let it
go to say
feed me the line let me just get that
line out or to just you know wear an
earwig and uh
you know i hear like you know i've heard
many stories robert downey jr he wears
it on all his movies he wears an aerobic
in every movie
you know and he sounds great he's down
soon in fact if someone's feeding you
the line i've talked about this in other
episodes
if they're feeding you the line john and
you hear it in your ear like you're
going i don't even want to talk to you
again you're right on top i'm like i
don't ever want to talk to you again
it's almost like it's coming out
naturally it's more natural than perhaps
saying the line as you normally would
well if i ever get a job again i should
try it out
inside of you is brought to you by in no
small
part thanks to our lovely supporters
over
on patreon folks if you enjoy the
podcast you love talking episodes you
want to stay involved with the inside of
you community
i highly suggest you check out what's uh
going on and what we're doing over at
the
patreon.com inside patreon it's uh
quickly turned into one of the coolest
things i've been a part of uh
certainly over the last year or so i
just it's become a family
i enjoy it uh we do little side things
like youtube uh
um i play music it's like a request line
and we all comment and do things you
just you got to be there
if you want to get early access to
episode content check out
the patreon if you want to interact with
other fans of the show
check out the patreon if you want to get
exclusive access to have your questions
asked during the show
to guests check out the patreon tech
look if you just love what we do and
want to keep this train
rolling check out the patreon doesn't
take much to get involved and i'm there
all the time chatting with folks and
putting together live hangouts
i literally would not be able to do this
without you guys without patreon
so thank you to get more involved in the
community today
head over to patreon.com inside of you
that's patreon.com inside of you
and i will see you there very soon
hey this is called [ __ ] talking with
john glover these are people going to
ask
questions from you from my they're
patrons of mine i have a thing called
patreon and they're going to ask you a
question this is from clawdeen
we've heard lots of stories from the set
of smuggler but is there one that hasn't
been
told yet that you can share the
naughtier the better
and please don't include me john well
there was the
peach one remember the peach one i think
i was on a massage table
covered by a towel and i just kept
wanting you to look down to my crotch
and
sort of render it huge
so wait wait i don't remember you put a
peach under the towel
no no no no no i was eating a peach it
was a very sensual scene
i had they had a you know a woman
masseur
i do remember this it was very
uncomfortable for me
yeah yeah and i did a thing where i got
up and sort of opened my towel and
everything and i
and i just said michael just when you
you
when i open it like that just glance
down and give me a look of amazement or
something
i remember you had like underneath it
didn't you have like those little those
underwear those
uh they made your other those little
underwears
yeah i do remember that i did a shower
scene too
where i was with these stuntmen in the
in the shower
and i i must say was it prison were you
in prison at the time
must have been yeah they sent somebody
to to uh
to stab me you had to kill me in the
shower yeah remember that
oh the prison days hey brian h
brian h says what role you've played do
you think
comes closest to you in real life oh
well i always use me so they're always
sort of parts of me um but what's part
like obviously you weren't lionel luther
you're not this
no but i when i when i played those two
uh
twins and terence's terence mcnally's
play level or compassion
i mean they i i mean i used both sides
of me
one who was loving and one who was
paranoid
because i i do both very well
yes you do yeah um emily s what's your
favorite thing about
being on fear of the walking dead
working working on a really interesting
role
that's got a lot of twists and turns and
surprises in it
and and i could use myself who was your
favorite actor
on the show that you worked with are you
allowed to say that
maybe not allowed to say that why not
you could say it who's your favorite
person on set that was there that you
really enjoyed oh jenna elfman
although i mean i wanted to work with
her for a long time
basically she shot a gun out of my hand
so we didn't really get to
work work together but
i was close but she was fun and keith
carradine
uh carly h scrooge is one of my ultimate
favorite christmas movies and bryce is
such an amazing
slimy yuppy baddie what is your favorite
memory from the shoot and how does it
feel to be a part of so many people's
holiday season
i had a great time and bill murray was
so much fun to work with
and what there was something i can't
remember
but he there there was some i had
was we shot it at paramount and there
was once there was one set
that was two sound stages that were put
together and i had to
walk him across to an elevator and walk
him on it
and and he said well i have lived
something
and i couldn't think of anything and and
all through lunch i kept thinking what
can i say what can i say
and uh and i came back and said
something that was sort of he said ah
that's so ordinary
he said what about that and i can't
remember what it was
but i knew it was really good and i
walked him all the way across
really silent and just as the uh the
elevator door was starting to close i
said the line
and it was like a devastating line it
was sort of meant his failure
and it just sort of went like that and
they kept it that was what was in there
yeah yeah and that was a line that he
gave you
yeah yeah was he very giving was he
playful on set was he fun
yeah but like you are because he's weird
and the character he plays was weird so
he
i mean he's very similar to you
really acting style-wise yeah so what do
you mean he gets
when the camera rolls he's in and then
when it's off he's just like himself
no but he's because he uses when he's on
camera to
sort of make it kind of go like that
veronica k what do you look forward to
doing most now that it looks like we're
nearing the end
of the lockdown we see the light at the
end of the tunnel what do you look
forward to doing
most a play with a live audience
sitting out there laughing there or
weeping or doing whatever
but being in a
who are your some of your personal
heroes adam arkham
became a good friend of mine really yeah
yeah and i
i he's a really good good generous guy
yeah he's helped me a lot yeah
you know welling's been on the podcast a
few times and he just admires you every
time we're anywhere at a con or whatever
he always talks about what a great actor
you are what a great man you are
and what a great role model just a
mentor yeah
you know the the last uh time you know i
i i kind of crashed you you you got you
two do this
sort of thing smallville nights yeah
yeah yeah
and the first time i did it was a lot of
fun
and then i did it a second time and i
stayed at the dinner table
drinking too much red wine oh yeah you
were drunk
and i felt i made a fool of myself
and i just want to apologize no no no no
no no look here's the reality you had a
few drinks you're having fun people knew
they're like oh john he had a little fun
he got a little lit
no but we i handled it we handled it it
was fine yes i did but i
but i was not happy with myself so i
just
in public want to apologize to both of
you well
you don't apologize to us but we we love
you regardless but uh
do you do you are you super hard on
yourself like
do you always stress about like when you
film something afterwards you're like
recreating the moments and the scenes do
you still do that
oh sure yeah i can tear myself apart by
the time i get home
yeah i think like what did i do how do
you shut it off how do you just let it
go you think at your age by now
you would be able to think right because
because i'm asking this because
i want to have some kind of semblance of
hope that
when i maybe i turn 60s 70s i'll stop
giving a [ __ ]
but you don't stop giving a [ __ ] right
but sometimes
i get uh overly uh paranoid i have
tendency
to for paranoia i think it came from
hiding so long
from hiding about who i really am your
sexuality
huh your sexuality yeah yeah i had to
i pretended for a long time and what was
so interesting was
that i remember confessing to my
to my um my my relatives down in
virginia
my cousin patty who's nine years older
than me
known me since i was born i mean
she was nine when i was born so i've
known her forever
and i confessed to her why i sort of
lost communication because i was living
with
somebody and my mother wanted it to stay
among the family which meant the three
of us
and she just looked at me and she said
oh johnny we've known you've been gay
since you were a little boy
wow it doesn't look slow doesn't that
make you feel sad that you lost so much
contact when she would have really
understood you or she did understand you
yeah
and that's why i sort of i guess when it
came time to just
to stop it i just stopped
and i but i still sometimes feel like
second rate because of it what do you
mean second rate
well it's because i'm i'm different than
the other boys
it was it was hard especially when it
got to
junior high school and and high school
and stuff when
you know i was uncomfortable so but i
found i found
my strength in the theater i i uh
we we did a
lilliam a the play called lillium which
was
carousel was based on that musical and
and you had right readings in the
cafeteria and i just
read one little line i thought i did it
really well but they didn't notice me
so i got on the crew to change the stage
it was platforms in the cafeteria it was
in the round
so people had to carry things on and off
and i got a
black derby cap and a black turtleneck
and black pants
and i came out and started moving the
furniture and people started laughing
at me so i don't know what i was doing
but i was behaving you know i didn't say
a word
but by the end of the show i was getting
big laughs and i thought the teacher was
going to be
really really mad at me but she gave me
the play at the lead in the play the
next year
wow i guess and i could make people
laugh i had i had a control
something happened and and and they were
i was making them laugh and and they
were laughing at me enjoying themselves
and it felt so good especially probably
because you were going through such a
tough time
i know you're hiding that this is a
chance right right i said you're
probably could be somebody else
and they would appreciate that the jew
it was the me
i remember once i i i carol kane was a
good friend of mine
and she was um
you know the blonde
the blonde girl from from terry garr
somehow i i got alone with terry gar in
her house
you've never seen me i've i felt so
uncomfortable
like i should be somebody that i should
be some man here
with terry gar in the house and i was
like this
gay guy that didn't know what to say to
her i just
made myself so uncomfortable i make
myself uncomfortable around bernadette
peters
i i have such a crush on her and i saw
her when she was in high school and one
of the first things she did in new york
so and and i got to uh to do a
we did a tv movie together so i got to
play with her
and i just would go blah blah blah and
once we were all sitting around talking
and and she said i have a sister and i
said i'm an only child
and she said oh no wonder you're a
little chatterbox
[Laughter]
but i love her so much that i get a
little
uh starstruck when i'm around her you
still do the um the alzheimer walks
obviously you couldn't do it this year
this last year no no it got more and
more complicated
and i guess my dad's death further and
further away
so and the and the town harder and
harder to get to
yeah because i remember you used to do
the alzheimer walks and we helped raise
money and right yes with science stuff
we did a whole we got in trouble
actually because we did so many
smallville things
they they stopped they said no you can't
do that anymore
you can't you can't raise money for one
thing with a with a tv show or something
really
yeah yeah i didn't remember that yeah
that's weird
but but tom donated his bike somebody
bought his bike
we all made a quilt yeah yeah
yeah because my grandfather just died uh
this year will be
this november will be two years of
alzheimer's and his mother died of
alzheimer's so we always used to talk
about that so it was it wasn't the virus
was it no no it was alzheimer's he died
before
he died the november bef right before
the pandemic
oh i'm so glad my parents left us too i
would have hated to have
oh yeah yeah that's the worst way to die
i'm glad
i'm glad my grandmother's vaccinated and
she's playing poker again blanche and
west palm beach and she's able to
because i couldn't imagine her dying
from the
during the day your grandma's called
blanche yeah she's blanche and my dog's
blanche and my dog is irv and my grandpa
who died is irv so
that's how i roll that's how i roll well
listen uh did you enjoy this
talking to you yeah oh oh oh this was it
that's it
oh i thought we were gonna do it now no
this is
uh well listen maybe uh sometime you
could have me over after the pandemic
we'll have a swim
that'd be great you know because of the
debt work on getting
your vaccination michael yeah i'm going
to i'm going to get in a week you know
yeah it'll make everything uh easier
listen i love you to death thank you for
allowing me inside you for this
it was a lot of fun i love it i'm glad
you did it i'm leaving now
okay bye bye
well that was grand i mean
that hair that hair was intense and
i just love him talking about sleeping
with uh freddie mercury
yeah and they just didn't say anything
about it like no that's that's what we
did yeah
good day sir that's a good day i go was
he good in bed i
really don't remember how could you not
know if i had sex with barbra streisand
or something i'd
remember it no i get i mean i think
that's just the
that's the kind of night they were both
looking for they just sort of needed uh
yeah what's wrong with that two two men
two human beings wanting to
have some release and some fun that's it
and they did
and we'll never know what would happen
behind those doors i mean maybe freddie
mercury talked about john glover this
whole time find
me somebody to love find me
something too are we gonna get sued for
that from youtube christ i'll be fine
uh thank you again for all the wishes uh
for irv i love you guys
so dearly uh remember to go to
stageit.com get your tickets for the
stage at show on april 24th saturday 2
p.m 6 p.m pacific standard time
uh we're gonna be playing a lot of music
it's it's this one's for ur the stage it
and um yeah pretty uh awesome dog
the best irv was the best and um also if
you want to get any merch go to
sunspin.com
for hats lunch boxes shirts oh the cool
shirt i'm wearing right now
and the inside of you online store for
smallville stuff inside of you stuff
tumblers hats lunch boxes i have small
lunch boxes left not many
but um so grab one grab something grab
hold tightly
and patreon if you want to join patreon
join the patreon family
uh we love you and i'd love to have you
aboard i always write a message after
someone gets on there at patreon.com
inside why don't i name the top patrons
and call this one a day
let's do it nancy d mary b leah s
trisha f sarah v little lisa yukiko jill
e
bryant h lauren g nico
p robin s jerry w robert b
jason w apothean kristen k
amelia oh allison l lucas m raj c joshua
d
emily s cjp samantha m jennifer n jackie
p
stacy l carly h gen s jamal f janelle b
carrie b tap of the 272 not to be
confused with the 273
ashley ryan kimberly l e wow
messed it up you really [ __ ] it up
mikey marissa and eldon soprano
ramira beth b santiago m sarah f
chad w liam p ray a maya p maisha
c matt yes you're right maddie asked
kendrick ashley e shannon d
matt w belinda and kevin v james r chris
h
i was born dave h samantha bee spiderman
chase sheila g ray h tabitha
t misha n h you're amazing
damn it tom n suzanne b katie f liliana
a
michelle k hannah b michael s
talia m luke m andrew t betsy d claire m
liz j laurel chad b rochelle e nathan e
brandel
don't forget taylor k neil a marion meg
k meg k janelle p
trev l travel travel remember travel
dan and jennifer j wayne m diane r
oh jeddah oh jedi lorraine g
olga c corey m carrie h
veronica k big stevie w kendall t
lindsay m
carol d kdg sandy b angel m
eric c and rhiannon c rhiannon see i
don't know what i would do without you
guys
my patreon's rule you are the reason the
show really is rocking
uh there's a lot of love i mean thank
you all the listeners today and
especially those patrons who support a
little extra on the side
um i love you it means the world to me
um
and uh be good to yourselves and love
those animals please
love your animal you never know how long
they're going to be here and they
already live such short lives
um from my house here in the hollywood
hills
i'm michael rosenbaum well i'm brian and
waving to the camera ryan hello and uh
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of each and every one of you guys have a
fantastic week spread the word on the
podcast
and uh much love to you
[Music]